全部経営者のせいだよ。経営者は勉強し
ないからだよ。鉄上の1公引から身を
起こして自己検査の人生ですよ。時間の
使い方とお金の使い方を見ると大体その
経営者の未来は分かるよ。そこにあった
ものは何かって言うと音ですよ。青木サの
人生哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる話
。
今回はですね、生き残る中小企業と、ま、倒産していく中小企業の決定的な違いは何かということで、ま、
2024年に11年ぶりに1
万円を超えたりですとか、あとは従業員の退職が原因で経営が破綻してしまう従業員の対職型というのは過去最多であるという風に言われているというデータもあるんですけれども、
生き残る中小企業と倒産する中小企業の決定的な違いとい
について考えを教えていただけますでしょうか?
[音楽]
ま、そんなのシンプルって経営者の問題でしょ。ぶっちゃけた話。全部経営者のせいだよ。経営者が勉強しないからだよ。経営者が頑固だからです。経営者が
人終わりだからです。経営者が半保先を読めないからです。経営者が心志しが低いからです。
いや、もっとシビアに言うと生き残れない
中小企業っていうのは社会の変化について
いけないんですよ。そして、ま、もっと
ズバり言うとぶっちゃけ愛情がないと思う
よ、俺。社員に対して。本当に社員に対し
て愛情があったら経営者は襟り正して社員
の言うことに耳をかすし、業界で成功し
てる人のとこに教えを恋いに行くだろうし
、本気で半保先のこと考えて採用にも
取り組むだろうし、本気で育成にも
取り組むだろうし、本気で勝ちある商品を
何としても開発するぞと。本気で商品開発
に打ち込むだろうし、大体今の時代成AI
未だにガラ系とか言ってるやついるじゃん
。そんな経営者もダメだよね。で、精
なんてね、どのこのって使ってもいないの
になんか批判だけしてるとかさ、もう時代
遅れの浦島太郎って言うんだ。そういうの
本音を言っちゃうとぶっちゃけ経営者格差
が企業格差です。で、中小企業は経営者
同士がその業界でどっちがいい経営者かだ
よ
。だ、私の仕事だったら人材教育、研修系
コンサルティングの会社、組織
コンサルティングだけど、ま、うちはだ
IT系でもないし、金融でもないし、
あくまでも研修人一軸ですよね。ま、うち
の車内を見てもらったらわか
るっていうことだよね。だから研修会社で
社員の採用がうまくいっていない、社員の
モチベーションが低いとかそうやって悩ん
でる研修会社の社長がいるとしたら廃業し
た方がいいと思うよ。だってそれは
研修会社をする資格がないでしょ。迷惑
でしょ。営業されることが。だ自分が出来
儲けのために営業しちゃダめなんだよ。
いや、すごくね、ユニークな考え方かも
しれないけど、僕はこれが多分原点だと
思います。私はすごくそういう意味で自分
がコントロールできないことで大儲け
しようとはしてないんですよ。あくまでも
僕は農力開発鉄の1公引から見を起こして
俺能力してきたよ。自己検査の人生ですよ
。今自分のしてることは目標達成に役立っ
てるのか。いつも自分に呪問し、一生懸命
生きてきた。まずそれがコアでしょ。で、
幹部じゃんと僕の考え方に共感する人間が
幹部になってくわけだよね。で、幹部は僕
のこと好きですよ。僕の生き方を信じてる
よね。で、あ、社長と一緒に価値を
作り出していこう。じゃ、その価値って何
かって言ったら、世の中に必要とされる
仕事をしていこう。世の中の求めに応じて
もっともっと価値ある会社にしていこう。
ほら、倒産しようがねえじゃん。そんな
もん。分かる?そういう考え方なんだもん
だって。そうでしょ。で、もし仮に世の中
から必要とされないようなレベルであれば
価値がないんだから縮小しよう。そうなの
よ。それはだから潰れる会社はしょうが
ないんだよ。本当
ぶっちゃけしょうがない。それはね、価値
はないんだ。ごめんなさい。いや、そう
いうことなんだよ。
価値がないんだよ
。怒られるかもしんないけど。だって価値
があったら潰れないよ。僕はあの友人の
渡辺美きさんがね、2回倒産しになったと
。そん時にあのミきさんが言ってたんだ
けどお取先の銀行の遠取りがお金を貸して
くれたと。さんの会社は潰れちゃいけない
会社だと言われたと。俺泣きそうなったな
。その話聞いて。そこまで金融機関に
言わしめる何そのあり
方でやっぱり一部上しっかりわびね頑張っ
てコロナの時でも寝て起きたら5000万
マイナスだったんだよ。わ今だけど
サブウェイでまた復活3000点作る
ぞって頑張ってるよ。宅配でも頑張ってる
よ。居酒屋渡ではなく、今いろんな業体を
開発して外食業色々ね、1番潰れる会社も
多い世界じゃない。でもなんでつハ8のね
な、それこそ7つぐらいのとこから
スタートして世界のなんでわになった
かってこないだもFacebook見たら
渡辺美きさん亡くなったつ橋の社長の
思い出書いてましたよ。そこにあったもの
は何かって言うと音ですよ。音がその
Facebookの記事の中に感じられた
やっぱり人としてのあり方が素晴らしいん
。うん。決して甘い経営者じゃないし、
厳しいし。だけどそこにあるものは
やっぱり深いレベルの愛なんだよ。うん。
僕は今いろんな経営者と付き合ってるけど
、創業型経営者で強い経営してる人は基本
的にはもちろん経済的合理性そ番に強い
数字に強いのもあるよね。でもやっぱり人
を大切にする真心を持ってる人がやっぱり
存続していく。その反対は潰れ
るってことです。数字が弱くて人としての
あり方、人間としてのパーパス、目的が
曖昧で目先の尊徳ばっかり追ってるような
人はやっぱり長期的には難しいんじゃない
の。あの、うちの会社ってね、すごく
ラッキーなんですよ。正直最初っから選択
で大儲けしようなんて思ってねえんだもん
、俺。全然儲からない会社だった最初。で
も絶対不満足な人間関係が起因するね、
この世の中のあらゆる不幸
をなくしたいと選択が世の中に広まれば
外的コントロールが少なくなってシングル
マザーも減ると貧しさがこの世から
なくなっていったら犯罪も減ると僕はこの
思い
で長年やっていって儲からない仕事を
儲かるようにしただけなだよ。知恵絞って
研修をし
てコンサルティングって言ったってうちの
会社がやってきたことをうちで学んでる
経営者の方にこんな風にやってますよって
伝えてるだけだもん。こな間だもある経営
者に言われた青木さんの社員は本当に
素晴らしいって。どんな質問にも答えて
くれるって
。うちはこんなことやってます。あんな
ことやってますで無償で何でも答えるとえ
そこまで教えていいんですかと。教えて
いいよって僕は言ってるからですよ。ただ
やってることだけ言いなさいと。絶対持っ
た話もしちゃだめだし、できないこと言っ
ちゃだめだよと。うちはこんな風にやって
ますよと。こういう理念ブック持ってます
よとか、毎朝こういう調礼やってますよと
か、やってることだけ正直に話しなさいと
。こういう会社は潰れません。なんだろ。
まず時間の使い方とお金の使い方を見ると
大体その経営者の未来分かるよ。僕は本当
に社員とその家族を守れる会社を作ろうと
思って頑張ってきたもん。グレイト
プレスワーク110カ国に調査してる。
その調査で一応日本では100人から
999人の中では1番になったからね。で
もそれはいい会社にしたいと思ってきた
からですよ。以上って感じかな
[音楽]
。ま、だからやっぱり時代を読んで時代に
やっぱりこう合わせて変革していかないと
いけないよね。そしてやっぱり経営者とし
て本気でいい会社にしようという決意を
持って向かうってことです。だから今の
この時代ね、インターネットがバーンと
伸びたと同じようにAIもこれからガーン
と伸びていくので、そういうあらゆるその
情報を集め
ながらね、中小企業でも社員数はまだ
少なくても経営者が率先して勉強してまず
は今の社員を豊かにできる系をどうしたら
できるだろうかってAIに聞いたらいいよ
。チャットGPTに。いや、僕毎日聞いて
ますよ。
本当にチャットGPTは使えるよ。だから
もう専属秘書みたいなもんだもん。そう
いう思考の柔軟さ、前向きな心を持った
経営者は潰れません。あとはやっぱり人を
大事にするってことだよね。ま、究極は己
より優れたものと共に働く技を持つものに
眠るとアンドリーカーネギーというね、
ナポレオンヒルに成功の研究を依頼したん
だけれどもまさに
墓に刻んだこの言葉
が成功する経営者の本質を表してると思い
ます。だからできる限り良い人材を集めね
、そして育て、価値ある事業をしっかりと
作り込んでいただきたいなという風に思い
ます。あともうたくさん僕あの
YouTubeで100、え、340もう
そう系に関する話してますので、是非ね
YouTubeしっかり他の番組も是非見
ていただいて、え、この問に対する答えを
自分の中で見つけてもらえればと思います
。是非チャンネル登録してください。
そして、あの、色々インスパイアしたこと
があればコメントにね、是非、あの、
コメント欄の方にもお願いします。また次
の番組でお見りかりましょう。ありがとう
ございました
。決して負けない経営だ。まず経営者自身
がお金よりも仕事の内容をそのものに
掘れ込んでるかどうかな。